So here we are in the heart of Silicon Valley at Google.
Machine learning is all over Silicon Valley.
>> Yeah, here at Google we're using machinery for, obviously for search, for
ranking the little pages that you going to see, for speech recognition, for
language translation and of course, for self driving cars.
>> One of my favorite examples is a little bit more trivial than that, but
I think it's really fun.
There is a company in Silicon valley that I actually tell it what clothes I
like, and then it'll figure out what my tastes are and
it'll sell me new clothes so I don't ever have to go shopping gain.
>> It is a machine learning algorithm?
>> It is a machine learning algorithm.
It is. >> So how did you have to train it?
>> It's really good, I didn't have to train it that long.
>> Wow. So is there a 10% bonuses?
>> I think, there probably, there should be, right?
>> [LAUGH] Here we go.
So Day, age of big data, yeah?
And, there is no company within a 10 mile radius that wouldn't use big data,
including Udacity, to optimize its products.
>> So, that's what we'll be learning about in this class,
there's all kinds of interesting examples here.
And, we'll go in great depth into a few questions in this class, but you should
always be thinking about interesting problems that you'd like to solve, and
how machine learning can help you out there.
>> And look, if you do a great job.
We do our best to find you a job here in Silicon Valley.